this is an 8 news now breaking news  alert  we will get to those stories in just a  moment but first here at 11 the couple  from indianapolis that went missing  traveling through nevada has been found  we're talking about ronnie and beverly  barker's nephew telling 8 news now that  authorities say his uncle was found dead  his aunt is alive she's been airlifted  to a reno hospital the couple went  missing last week they were driving an  rv from oregon to arizona now family  tell us the rv was found empty earlier  this afternoon some 30 miles from the  nearest freeway the nevada civil air  patrol had four aircraft in the sky  today helping with that search but we  don't know if one of those crews spotted  the rv